the officers that are going to be
participating in this training will be
getting the most realistic training as
possible there will be simulated gunfire
some simulated explosions we have over
50 role players with our explorers and
our metro volunteers that will be acting
as teachers for the school as well as
children for the school so our officers
know
what they might encounter when they go
in there as well as dealing with any
threats
we're doing this training to be as
realistic as possible so god forbid if
something like this does befall upon our
valley our officers will not hesitate
they will not flinch they will quickly
and decisively take action i can assure
you that no matter what
agency responds no matter what uniform
you see
like in this training today there's
other agencies besides metro and school
police participating the officers as
soon as they get there will not wait
they will go in not hesitate find the
suspect and do whatever they need to do
to stop the killing inside of that
school